let's bring in Nick nurse cotton entire
Coach's Corner the Toronto Raptors head
coach before we get to all the glory in
the parade and Kauai can you name in
order all of the coaching stops before
you got to the Toronto Raptors I think I
did okay okay start at Northern Iowa
student assistant grand new University
Darby
dams South Dakota Birmingham bullet
Ostend and Belgium Manchester giant
London towers
Brighton bears Iowa energy Rio Grande
Valley Vipers Toronto Raptors wait what
about the Oklahoma Oklahoma storm there
was a couple of some early stuff in
there to Oklahoma storm with the summer
or the summer times gave at the USBA oh
and coasting along beach summer league
as well when it was back at Long Beach
and a few stamps in the Vegas summer
league as well get to mom basketball
Without Borders you know anybody would
give you a team to coach down I would I
would take it you played at the
University of Northern Iowa are you
still the school's all-time leading
3-point shooter I don't think so and I
might I might have one record here there
for that but I think the three-point
shot is evolved past night my generation
what's the moment during the NBA Finals
that you'll remember aside from the
final buzzer but was there any game
where that one moment where you just I
don't know it'll always stand out to you
well I think it's not it's not during a
game so I'm always going to remember it
was I think it was game four and Oakland
in the locker room I was I was coming in
to kind of give my last view film clips
and talk to the team and and somebody
had written let it rip on the dry erase
board and as I was walking in I looked
at Kyle hour and I said did you
you write that on the board and he goes
no but that's the way I feel and that
was a pretty cool moment he went out and
played you know he went out and finished
the next the next three games or so and
just played unbelievable basketball and
I don't know I'll never forget it my
assistant coach Adrian Griffin was the
one who actually wrote it on the board
so the cool kind of player coach moment
he's the Raptors head coach Nick nurse
joining his Continental Tire Coaches
Corner
were you waiting for any announcement
from Kawhi Leonard during the parade
celebration that maybe he was going to
be coming back so many people are dead
it probably would have been a long time
to do it the excitement was already at a
at an unbelievable level at that parade
end of the parade celebration and
grumbly wise in his part not not to make
any announcements on that and I keep
hearing Kawhi Leonard's got a great
sense of humor it's sort of like the New
England Patriots always say man Bill
Belichick is really funny so give me
give me an incident where I go okay
Kawhi Leonard good sense of humor funny
guy well he got me really good one time
in a film session it was we just want
three two it gets Milwaukee we were back
at home and you know everybody was going
bonkers in Toronto that we were maybe
going to go to the final and I was
trying to tell the guys you know don't
don't let people take it to someplace
you weren't to yet and I was relating a
story and I didn't do this I don't think
once all year about got my D League
coaching days and I was trying to tell
them that that we were we were in the
finals I was coaching Iowa and we were
in the finals against Rio Grande Valley
and you know nobody gave us much of a
chance I think we just had four of our
best players called up in the first and
second rounds of the playoffs and and we
went down through the best two out of
three first came on the road next to at
home and we went down to Rio Grande
Valley in one game won by like 17 points
and came back to Des Moines and I know
it
the d-league and minorly but they were
excited the city with city was super
excited oh my god we're going to win a
championship and they're planning
parades and asking for ring sizes and
our players just couldn't handle it when
I got beat by 25 in Game two and I was
trying to tell that story and he was
like when I talked about the parade and
the ring and the d-league wait a minute
you talking about the d-league as I'm
done listening to this story he got me
pretty good and I had I got some
pictures out showed him know we had 14
thousand people at the game and all this
stuff he did he didn't really know that
big dope
kind of blew up your moment there yeah
yeah it killed me it killed me I had
that really regroup and finished the
story out so I knew it do you think
Kauai is coming back and you can hold on
but do you think yeah I don't know and I
think that you know that any
conversations I've had with him I never
really asked him specifically and never
talked about it all year long but early
on in the year I you know I had some sit
downs with him and and the only thing he
ever talked about was that he wanted to
be healthy and play a long time and that
all he wanted to do was win he never
would go anywhere about personal goals
or or a you know MVP none of that none
of that stuff he wanted to ever even go
down that road and I think that one the
level of care we gave him our medical
team Alex McKechnie runs that and he's
you know widely respected around the
world for how good he is and I think
that's important to Kauai and I think
that that more than anything may weigh
in on the decision but also when you
start this load management here and
that's the new you know buzz phrase but
what is your role is the coach with load
management for a guy only played 60
games during the regular season
yeah I mean I I just got to get on board
with it then and I think that not only
with him I was I was trying to long play
the season just because I thought we had
a chance to make a run right we had a
grantor roster we had a good team coming
back and we tried to you know we did a
thing in three in training camp where we
talked about April May and June you know
we had a little AMJ slogan that we were
trying to play everything for April May
and June and so that kind of fit into
that anyway and I was concerned when we
got him who knew exactly where he was he
hadn't played in a year really and there
was gun I thought there would be some
some early season slow build-up no just
just for that fact alone and then it
kind of it was kind of working our team
was kind of playing well the night he
didn't play I think we went 17 and 5 or
something like that yeah the the load
management game sort but for me it
lifted a lot of pressure because the
players were playing so well when he
didn't play and I think they were on
board they knew we were just trying to
get him back easing back and let him let
him feel his way through it a little bit
and I think everybody was on board so it
wasn't a big deal you know yeah and I
was worried your legacy was gonna be
that timeout you called in game 5 if it
went south it was like oh no don't be
remembered for this you dodged it but
did you ever talk it out to coach I'm
fun in the offseason it's gonna go real
quick and you're gonna be ready to go
this upcoming season hopefully you get a
chance to have a fully assembled line up
there but Congrats well done hey thanks
a lot man big fan Thank You Nick for
more Dan Patrick show tune in the
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV stream
for free on Br
live or download the Dan Patrick show
app
[Music]